so waking up is one task remembering
that the founding generation which is
who I went back to for my book give me
liberty to recall from them what core
values were supposed to have and what
we're supposed to believe in order to
fight the subversions of liberty that
we're facing because I feel like we've
been encouraged to forget those values
with what I call fake patriotism leading
us to accept a fake democracy in many
ways but the founding generation would
have wanted us to take on board an inner
conviction that it is our right to ask
these questions and to not be passive
and you know accept this kind of fake
patriotism that our role is to just
support the government no matter what it
does or support any military
intervention no matter what that is not
what the founding generation I mean
ordinary people not just the well-known
founders you know farmers and and washer
women and artisans and enslaved
african-americans they were captivated
by this vision of Liberty and they
intended us to have this kind of inner
courage to challenge the government
that's what the Declaration of indepen
says the second paragraph is challenge
the government any time it tries to be
tyrannical or oppressive it is your duty
to rebel the third thing we can do is
lobby our attorneys general in our
district attorneys to prosecute those in
the bush administration who have
committed high crimes and misdemeanors
so this is partly strategic I was on the
phone this morning with Charlotte
dennett who is a running for attorney
general in Vermont and she's promised
that if she's elected she will prosecute
George Bush for murder and there are
many other organizations from Amnesty
International to Human Rights Watch to
the American freedom campaign who are in
discussion right now with attorneys
about possible prosecutions of bush and
senior officials and this is not
rhetorical there's evidence that they've
committed multiple crimes whether it's
violating the law local and
international
stick intl on torture or whether it's
advancing an illegal war in Iraq or
whether it's wiretapping illegally
without you know violating the Fourth
Amendment without warrants I personally
am investigating whether the deployment
of troops and the militarization with
Homeland Security money of local police
departments that you saw in the
brutality in st. Paul right during the
Republican National Convention I'm
investigating right now with lawyers
whether that constitutes treason and I
think if it does he should also be
prosecuted for treason here's why the
Constitution defines treason as making
war against the United States and I
think it's very arguable that deploying
troops against the people of the United
States and certainly militarizing their
local police forces with more and more
lethal technologies in order to subdue
and subjugate citizens and strip them of
their First Amendment rights is making
war against the United States but I'm
not a lawyer so I'll get back to you on
that but definitely what we can do is
lobby our attorneys general and district
attorneys to prepare prosecutions and
move forward with indictments and arrest
and in trials